it's time for the long gene horoscope a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene but nor
what's company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching Chronos code from the CBS
television news staff larry lesser and
don Hallenbeck our distinguished guest
for this evening is colonel irene of
galloway director of the Women's Army
Corps this week we celebrate Armed
Forces Day three times in the past ten
years we've been forced to wonder
whether our troops will be forced to
fight on foreign soil in fact in the
past 10 years the threat a world war has
never been remote if such a disaster
should occur of course women would be
needed as much as men my Colonel
Galloway or the director of the Women's
Army Corps I asked for a start just how
many women are under your command now
well Larry right now we have 8,500 women
however you remember during World War
two we had about oh I would say
approximately 100,000 women serving at
one time we had 150,000 women unless sit
in the car during World War two see so
they're just about 10,000 12,000 now you
see that's right how many of those are
overseas colonel we have about 30%
overseas serving in Okinawa Japan
Germany France and Italy Oh Colonel
Calloway before I ask why women join the
army may I ask you why you joined up
well Larry it was in June of 1942 was
coming from st. Patrick's Cathedral
friend and I were discussing the article
we had just read in the new New York
Times that morning of the possibility of
women joining service so the next Monday
morning we found ourselves down
Whitehall
in lists just like that do you I suppose
you had possibly relatives in the army
I had a brother serving on the Pacific
and I felt I too should do something
well may I ask Colonel Galloway do you
find now that there are objections from
parents about their girls going into the
Army not too much
there always says I would say some
reluctant on the part of parents to see
a young daughter leave home whether it's
to go to college into business or into
service however any girl under 21 years
of age must get parental consent to
coming to the service well at what age
do you accept people in the Women's Army
Corps 18 to 35 years of age however we
still have quite a few limited service
from World War two and we have one woman
who was just recently had her 60th first
birthday how's your rate of reenlistment
colonel
quite high and I was very pleased
finding that some of the women who felt
that they perhaps would like to have a
career in civilian life have read now
returned to the service after being up
spelling life for two or three years
they find they have better opportunities
that it they feel so they have Vantage's
travel education in fact I feel the
opportunities for women in service are
unlimited it depends upon an individual
women apparel may I ask you discussion
oh what actually do do in the Women's
Army Corps now to make the career of
being a woman in the army attractive to
women do you if I may say so do
something about their uniforms about
their hats well we don't feel we have to
make the career attractive actually if a
woman is in service I feel that she
recognizes it is an attractive career
yes that the point is to get them to the
point of getting over the hurdle and
getting into the service isn't it the
case well Larry what we try to do is
stress the opportunities and furthering
our education the opportunity to travel
not only that they a woman can have a
satisfying career but in addition she
can contribute service to her country
you've smart enough that you know comp
since World War two something has been
done about that and altered the hat that
you wore when you came in here well I
tell you what we've done Larry we've got
rid of the ties such as one you're
wearing right now we feel it more
comfortable with the small collar not
having the tie on the high shirt such as
you are I think we learned by degrees
when I would say that what type of
uniform was more comfortable I think you
really recall we start with the hobby
hat yes I remember this and this has
hands now it's much softer more feminine
looking at and you have still have
prominent designers doing these things
Harry Carnegie's designed our prayers
that uniform yes well in other words it
is possible for a woman to be in service
to be military and shipshape may use an
old expression as well as feminine well
I think so what I think you have to have
food that what are what are a woman's
chances for advancement and Commission
say is compared to a man's in the army
just as good or not so good or better
there again it depends upon the
individual any enlisted woman if she
qualifies can't become an officer or a
college graduate can apply for a reserve
Commission and concurrent call to active
duty what do you find women like to do
best in the army
some prefer the medical field x-ray work
laboratory work others prefers
communications what are those two most
puppies as you say what do they do best
that's what they like best what do they
do best though when you feel in there
dude what do you think women are best
suited for in the army though
well I wouldn't restrict that to the
army Larry it all depends upon the
individual again and I think that more
and more we realize that when we speak
of manpower we do include woman power
because there is a critical shortage
I see another life for women the Army is
no different from the opportunities also
that exist are the things they can do in
79 no I would say not and I think that
the past few years have shown that women
are becoming more and more prominent in
government I ask you this question is
speaking about women becoming prominent
in government now I don't make any
comment about women in government but
does the army actually change women
would you say do you think it hardens
them does it make them on masculine your
self excused of good no I would say that
first of all I would say that a young
woman character is developed before she
enters the army no I mean a young
woman's character is already formed when
she enters the service her character is
developed we encourage her her to
develop and become self-reliant and we
try all week as much as possible by
example and precept to make her an
outstanding citizen make you recognize
her citizenship responsibilities her
responsibilities as an individual and as
a woman what is the presence of women in
the Army due to the masculine side of
the army Annie yes I do that does it
have an effect on the morale of the men
are women possibly troublemakers or do
they make the men feel as though they're
any more home-like atmosphere
well I'm being a woman I would say that
we have a stabilizing influence
stabilizing such as can you be some more
specific well at the present time I
don't think that well I would say men
except limited service so we aren't new
10 or 12 years ago was a little
different but now they realize that
women do have a place in service and we
work side-by-side with the man pretty
much as it would be any other way if I
may bring up a rather a touchy subject
in some corners I was in Korea last year
when our army was in combat over there
and I know you're a veteran of World War
two one of the things that amazed me
most was the news site of our army and
the absence of segregation in it in
World War two as you remember the army
was almost completely segregated up
until the last battles the battles of
the Bulge and there are dens but in
Korea now the army is completely non
segregated and I just wanted if you're
Women's Army Corps follow the same
pattern as our modern army now do you is
there segregation in the Women's Army
Corps when you speak of segregating a
non segregation Korea Larry I hate to
correct you but I have to there is no
segregation the army
that's what executive I was referring to
there is none in in the army but what
about the Women's Army Corps though
there is no segregation next we don't
even think of it anymore
you follow exactly the same patterns and
and you mix a colored wax with white
army troops in the various military
installations our all of our women live
in the same balance work side by side
and you have you found this to be a
successful method very satisfactory
we're proud of all of our women in
service
incidentally I was in Korea too last
year and visit the Korean army we have a
WAC counterpart in Korean army I see and
the American women in the Korean army
know the Korean army has a WAC
counterpart of some of the things that
they've picked up you let me ask you
though finally they Colonel Galloway
what would you say I think all women are
interested in Korea's what opportunities
actually exist for women in the army are
they equal to those of men can they get
married what do you think
okay now only can they do but would you
say that they're that the opportunities
to rise in the army are as good for
women as they are for men every bit as
good that every opportunity we are in
the same career field
actually we the women in service serve
in 19 of the 32 career fields in case of
outright war we is serving 27 32 career
fields we serve in any type of duty that
is culturally acceptable to the American
people of course we do not serve in
combat well thank you very much Gemma
Galloway we salute you done and I the
opinions expressed on the lawn giancana
scope were those of the speakers the
editorial board for this edition of the
launching Cronus cope was Larry Lazar
and Dan Hollenbeck our distinguished
guest was Colonel Irene o Ganaway
director of the Women's Army Corps